So, thank you Sara. This was helpful. It's pretty nice to know that HTML and
CSS aren't actually all that complicated. So
thank you for lifting the veil on that.
>> Yeah. Definitely there's definitely more to it
than just what we did here. It would
definitely take more practice and familiarity to start
you know building pages of this complexity, but I
>> You mean from scratch I bet is a little harder?
>> Yeah a little bit.
>> But
it's cool to be able to modify open source projects.
>> Yeah and it's nice to be able to actually just, you know
look at the source for any page you know you could just, any
>> Change Google to Boogle.
>> Yeah. If you wanted, you could
>> I don't think I want to.
>> You could just look at [LAUGH] Any, any page
that, that you're visiting, you can always just look at the
source code and see what they're doing and learn a little
bit that way. See what, what standards there are out there.
Cool.
>> Yeah.
>> I can't wait to see all the projects that the
students in this class come up with. I'm sure they'll be some
>> Yeah. It'll be awesome.
>> Some good ones. And next time, we're going to make [INAUDIBLE] button.
>> Yeah. So we'll, we'll look at the JavaScript in more detail.
And add in the functionality and then throw a button on the HTML.
>> Cool. Alright. See you then.